foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign foreign
mistakes
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
to say
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
okay I'll do this in English now it is
my absolute pleasure to Welcome to the
stage the president of the European
commission Ursula
thank you very much and what a pleasure
to be here in krenheit
indeed the two words
were words that accompanied me in all my
childhood but they were a little bit
like these distant fairy tales where you
have these these words that are
childhood words but I I never thought
that they are reality so it was
wonderful for me today to walk through
cairnheim and to see all that what were
the childhood fairy tale tales that I
did here so thank you very much for
having me here and many many things also
for the wonderful tour that we had the
guided tour that we had and the nice
lunch in one of the old factories so
really amazing
I learned
um that the cranheim cotton mill when it
was built in 1857 actually almost 100
years before I was born
it was powered by 11 water turbines so
that was new for me too Renewable Power
at that time already 160 years ago or
more than 160 years ago from the Nava
waterfall and you all know of course the
beautiful view on the the course that
the waterfall did carve into the stone
and I learned also that the history of
your town of course traces so much of
the history of Estonia a story of
Commerce and trade but also a story of
war and occupation but in the very end
the story of Independence and resilience
and this is what brings us here together
today because together
we are writing the next chapter in your
truly inspiring story
I am delighted to announce that today
we're launching estonia's just
transition fund
the European Union is investing
354 million euros in edaviro County
to support your Region's Fair transition
to a modern low carbon
low carbon economy
and I think you've said it already kayam
this will bring jobs to the region it
will bring growth to the region jobs and
growth that are reliable
because they are investing in tomorrow's
economy so it's something which will
last
for example in wind energy year on
decade after decade this technology will
grow
I joined you when we had the Baltic wind
Summit amazing to see the offshore wind
Summit it was in August and we agreed on
targets if we're able to bring that
project up and running
that will cover the energy consumption
of around 6 million households by 2030.
it's not so far away it's in eight years
we have to be there six million
households that is more than the number
of
the households in Estonia in Latvia in
Lithuania and in Denmark combined so
that gives you an idea what an amount of
power is possible in the North Sea for
example
in Estonia three major offshore Wind
forms are already planned with a total
capacity of almost 1 500 megawatts
this is nearly as much as your County's
current power generation capacity which
largely comes from this region
and this is why the Energy company SD
energia has been able to announce that
all its power production should come
from wind and solar by the end of this
decade
this I think still seems far away but
it's pretty close I mean end of this
decade as I said eight years is a
winning business case for idavaru
because you have even more
this region is very rich for example I
learned that of rare earth metals and
you have a lot of digital knowledge here
and that is what is needed for the new
circular green economy
the just transition fund will help
create these new companies or modernize
the old ones that are here already it
will bring research it will bring new
jobs into the region
you're just transition fund foresees and
you know it investment in the founding
of new firms
investment in research and innovation
investment in upskilling and reskilling
programs and investment in
digitalization
and this is where the future lies to
take advantage of the necessary
transition the transition to other forms
of energy this is necessary but take
advantage of it modernize strengthen the
resilience of your economy and this is
not only realistic but I think this is
also very strategic what we're doing
here
because renewable energy is home grown
it's produced at home
it is homegrown like oil shale
you know it both energy sources can
underpin your independence from Russia
in the short term
but unlike Shale Renewables are also
good for our health and they are good
for our climate and that's not even all
Renewables have a long-term growth
perspective which fossil fuels don't
have
so a lot is in this business case we
just have to make the ends meet and make
sure that the investment is there that's
now here with the just transition fund
for the region your just transition plan
means more modernization it means more
diversification and it means long-term
Independence
I want to especially thank you for the
very close and very constructive
cooperation that all of you have been
bringing to the table and are still
bringing to the table so the Estonian
government
the local authorities
the companies and the trade unions
and the community's most affected here
in edaviru that is amazing how you set
together how you join forces how you
turned every stone around and took every
good idea put it in the basket so that
now we're able really to deliver on the
promise that is written down there as I
saw the 354 million euros
the Jazz transition plan is as you know
designed as an open process an inclusive
process we want everybody in because
it's your ownership you own that plan
that will drive the change we need you
know this region you know where the
opportunities are we can help with
perhaps some advice or we can help with
research bringing to the region we can
help with the funding but you own this
region you own this knowledge and you
have a vision for the future you know
where training technology and
technological support is needed most you
know what's necessary to empower the
workers perhaps the small business
owners and especially young people who
want their Community here to thrive
so I would really want from the bottom
of my heart to thank all of you all of
you that are present here today I want
to thank you for your leadership because
that was necessary you needed really to
bring everything together and then show
leadership to make this happen
your work matters
to the people of viru and for Europe to
be a force for good at the progress for
all Europeans
my dear friends standing here by the
narva river and I've seen it now from
different angles it's amazing I mean for
you it's familiar but for me it's a
wonderful experience
narva river which was once
one of the biggest industrial centers
and I can really literally feel
that if you look at history sometimes
history is like a river like this Nava
River it does not flow in a straight
line
history bends it has its curves it has
sometimes a waterfall there are Rapids
and there are rocks which we could see
out there but every river has a clear
Direction even if it is going in many
many different ways towards the
direction
and with the just transition fund we
want to shape that direction to flow to
a better place we want to move forward
together with you to make iraviro a
center of progress again
with your resilience
your ingenuity
your fantastic ideas
Your Enthusiasm your hard work and with
Europe's solidarity
I'm very confident that we can do that
many many thanks for that and Long Live
Europe thank you
thank you